[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
sometimes a really long time i'm link
and i'm rhett
this week at the round table of dim
lighting
is the second part of our
conversation that we just finished that
we recorded last
for that you listened to last week but
we were sat down and we recorded it all
at the same time basically what happened
as we indicated last week
is that we were having a conversation
about board games
and i brought up my repeated accusation
of link
which is that i feel like he's just as
competitive as me
and that opened a huge can of worms
about
oh man it just got oh
what and i don't know exactly when
kiko's gonna decide
so what we're about to play for you in
the conversation it might overlap a
little bit it might backtrack a little
bit with where last week's
ended before we cut in i don't know kiko
how you're gonna do this but
um i think you you think this is an
important conversation and i think
it will um make you
feel better to know uh
that we've had this conversation already
that you're about to listen to
and everything is okay yeah we're still
good we are okay
it you know it got kind of intense in a
couple of places
um but i think it was a good
conversation
i'm glad that it happened i don't know
how you're going to interpret it
but as we said at the end of last week
as you interact with this conversation
uh
as you listen to it and then as you talk
about it online we would just
ask that in the spirit that we tried to
embody
as we had the discussion which is a
spirit
of uh goodwill
i would say it's like we said some we
said some hard things or whatever
but uh this the whole point of this is
is not for it to become some competition
between the two of us
where you're like well i think that
rhett was right or i think that link was
right or
we how can we be illuminating in the way
that we continued the conversation
right how can you be how can we all
understand
each other more yeah and what does this
make you think about yourself
you know not just what you think about
one or both of us but like how do you
relate to some of the things that we're
saying
and what does it make you think about
your own personal journey and the way
that you see
the world and maybe this is i mean
maybe this isn't the end of the
conversation but it's the beginning of
the conversation
and i'm not talking about this episode i
don't know i just you know i don't know
how much it
like i mean there's more to talk about
you know we made it sound like it's just
this is like crazy
yeah i don't think we built it up too
much yeah we put it up
a conversation about board games became
a conversation about our friendship and
the way that we view
the interplay between the two of us well
just and here it is
and now you can listen to it here it is
[Music]
ultimately everybody wants to be
important in some way right and people
who are in
entertainment kind of achieve that
and find their purpose a lot of times in
you know
eliciting a reaction from people and i
would say that
you are actually even more
focused and committed to getting a
reaction
from a crowd or from a from an
individual than i am you think about
like the way that you're
super you know i'm much i'm much less
concerned about things like
where is this thing and where is the
camera and am i showing am i opening
this box in the right way
in my mind that's all competitive nature
it's like
that you have a commitment to excellence
and you may you're you're thinking about
competitiveness in in like
i'm throwing a ball faster than a person
or not
but like you actually care about that
stuff more than i do and i
and i would call that sort of
pers i would almost say it's a
relentless pursuit
of doing things in a certain way
perfection is not
i mean is it is attained
comparison to like a standard
yes but i think it's a stretch to say
that that's competition like i'm
competing against the standard
now i also think this is
i think i think it's a little muddied by
i don't know i do you do you get from me
in this conversation
that like i judge you for being compass
that and i think that's that's
interesting
because i think that's really what's
going on is that your counterpoint is
you're ju you feel judged
by me for being competitive well i think
what i mean so then you're trying to
hey man i just don't i'm superior i
don't because i'm not competitive i
don't bother with like wanting to win
a stupid game over somebody that's
that's kind of but i don't
believe that i don't believe that i
think you're
i just i don't think that's happening
and i what i i guess
in what i'm saying so that's part of it
but i also what
one of the things i'm saying is that i
feel like
our entire career is
based on a competition ultimately i
think there's a competition
uh against ourselves and against
our like looking back on something that
we did and not liking it and wanting to
do better
well but seeing that as a competition is
because you're a competitive
person i i just don't like we're not
competing against ourselves
but we're also we're also constantly
competing against each other so you're
saying
that's part of it as well it's like you
think about you think about
the way me and you like to divide
everything up like i was like all right
we're going to do this meeting
so you're going to say these things and
i'm going to say these things don't say
more than me and we're and we're both
equally committed to that and so if you
think
i just don't think i view that as a
competition but but what
what is it if it's not a competition
it's something that i care about deeply
that's a different thing
that again i'm not judging you if you
see it as a competition
well if it's not but i don't but that's
just that's the way you look at the
world
and you when you see me acting the way
that you would again i think it's
something different like me being a
perfectionist to a flawed point
absolutely like i could be defensive
about like yeah i'm i'm i'm i think
about how i open boxes
like whatever you're i know exactly what
you're talking about i'm just i'm saying
that i think that that
and i don't think that's a bad thing
ultimately is what i'm saying i think
that that
is a sign of someone but i'm saying
there are things about me like i'm a
perfectionist
just like you could say i'm a
competitive person let's just i
and i'm saying well there are flaws
associated with that but
i'm not putting that on i'm not judging
you being competitive i'm saying
the only thing i guess i was insinuating
was
sometimes when you're when you're not
competitive and you're around
competitive people
it doesn't it's not a good time
but but that's not that's not a judgment
on
that because you're a bad person yeah i
think what i am saying
is i mean i think that that's par i
think
that is part of it but i think what i'm
saying is that
my understanding of the competitive
spirit
is something that i i think that there
are elements of your personality that
are based in
a competitive spirit yes and that's true
and much more than you give yourself
credit for it because i don't think it's
i don't think it's a bad thing right
because
whether you want to use the term
competitive or not
but it's just like you know and i and i
think that the
competition and i don't mean the the
staged competition
but in every relationship every marriage
every creative partnership
there's healthy competition if there's
not healthy competition
then it's just one person just doing
everything and getting their way
but that isn't that isn't the nature of
our partnership it's just like
i fight for ideas you fight for ideas
you have things that are important to
you i have things that are important to
me
and we we fight for those things right
and and the creative process
is is based
in a competitive a competitive spirit
i i think for you i think for me i want
things just as badly as you do
and for good reasons and bad reasons
but i just don't i don't look i
i don't look at that through a lens of
competition as readily as you do
and i i look through a different lens
depending on what the example
is and i i just think that's how
we see things differently and we things
resonate with us differently like
the more something is overtly
competition the more i am going
to shrink from it and the more you are
going to engage with it
i think that's the definition to me
that's the definition of are you
competitive person
when you're when you're faced with
something that's obviously competitive
how do you respond um
and again with no judgment attached to
that
you know yeah i get that yeah i think
it's
it's very simply that i just see it as
broader than that like i think that
even like we talked about this for years
like when when we
when me and you are
like when we're performing it's just
like
are you telli i refuse to believe
that there is not something in your mind
because
we've talked about it a million times
like if we're watching an edit of
something
that is more like we went out and did
something and now we're editing it
sure we balance we want to balance and
but we
we're not trying to achieve that balance
just in the name of
brand it's just like i'm i'm
fully ready i'm fully willing to admit
that it's just like
i want to be able to watch that video
and think
i contributed to the comedy in this
video like i got some good lines in
there
and if i watch a video i'm like man i
didn't really
i didn't really get to express myself in
the way that i would like to
if i could go back and engineer this
video it would be like a 50 50 thing
whereas you know what link got a bunch
of good one-liners in there in this
video
and now so for me
i'm saying that there is a what i think
is ultimately a healthy competition
it's not like oh i want to get more than
link i want to
i don't want link to say anything funny
because that would be like yeah i just
don't call that competition that would
be
so but what is it if it's not um because
i would think
if you could i don't view that as comp
first of all we agree
in what we're after like we talk we talk
about
balance a lot but so but the way that i
think like i just don't i don't think i
think about it in terms of competition i
don't think about it in terms of pulling
pulling my weight or what i'm
contributing it's personal though
i think ultimately what i'm saying is
that it is personally motivated it isn't
like
i'm trying to meet it's not like you're
trying to meet an external
quote quota of like we've decided and
sometimes
long past that we have 50 50
contributing to as
much as possible but it's like in the
moment when you're watching a video
and you're like i'm trying to get
i want to be an equal partner in this i
think
there's a con there's a an element of
competition that's based on
your advocate for yourself in a
non-prideful
healthy way in other words just like
if i were to go in and edit a video
without you being there
and you were like man i said a bunch of
funny things and he's edited those
things out
when i wasn't there you would be would
you be personally offended and would you
be offended
because we're not meeting some standard
or would you be personally offended
because
hey man i said some funny things and i
want the world to know about those
things
uh yeah i would be
i would be offended
because i would but i wouldn't be like
because i want to beat you
to me that i didn't talk i'm not talking
about beating but see that's what
see that's how i think of competition i
think of
um this example
is not competitive it's like
i mean
we're both if if we've had times when
we've thought
i want to be seen as funnier
than the other guy then i think that's
probably not a healthy level of
competition
um i i just i i
my instinct is that i just don't look at
it through a lens of competition
well but but i don't know so what is
healthy so what
no but what is it but if you're an
advocate for yourself
and there's a pie with a limited amount
of
contribution and i'm the other person
who's contributing to it
then what is it if it's i guess i want i
don't think it's a bad thing i agree i
agree with you that it would be bad if
it was just like
we either of us had a secret uh uh
you know agenda to belittle the other
guy
but for me a lot of times what hap what
happens is just us like
like we might do a live show right and
i'm like
we go out and i'm like we we've we've
done the show that night
and i'm like man i didn't bring a lot
tonight yeah right but but i'm also i'm
thinking about it in
in in the only other person on stage is
you right
and so naturally i'm gonna be like well
i didn't bring a lot tonight
link did bring a lot tonight so when i
think tomorrow night
i want to bring a lot not to be better
than him
but so that it will even out and so but
in doing that i am there there's a you
know
i'm personal i'm motivated i know but
you're not trying to beat me
but you but but you so you're you're
you're thinking the same thing i think
those same things too i was like man i
didn't
i the way i think about it is man i
didn't pull my weight
i didn't you know i'm glad that rhett
stepped up or
you know because then it would if if he
had a bad night too then that would have
suck i mean i think of episodes of
gmm that way it's like oh man i just
you know if i didn't
if i didn't pull my weight hopefully you
pulled more or
you know but really is that all it is
because what if what if every single
time you didn't pull your weight
i pulled more weight and what if it that
was the standard
and what if it was like man that would
bother you but why would it bother you
are you saying it wouldn't bother you
the times when i feel like i don't
perform well and you do perform well
like on an in a given episode or a given
thing
does that bother me would it does it
bother you in a single instance but does
it
what if that became the pattern would
that bother you
and what part of you would it bother uh
i it would absolutely bother me it
absolutely does bother me when it
happens
but i feel like i and it i direct
all that towards myself i don't look at
it through a lens of competition oh i
direct it towards myself completely
but but the person but the only other
person contributing to the mathematical
equation by which i judge myself is you
i i mean i certainly compare myself to
you
all the all the time and i reach certain
conclusions i think
and i i know that there's a healthy
you know when we're both at our best
i think i i think i got it's a kind it's
a um i'm just
i'm trying to get you to what i'm trying
to do is i
like okay we can use a different word if
you don't like the word competitive
but like okay well that's what we're
talking about let's say
i'm just saying i call that competition
you're right and that's my point exactly
okay
we both say i come to work we both know
how this works
to make it the best it can be all right
i think i got i think i got you i think
i'm about to get you
because because you can disagree with me
okay but let's say that
we go to a uh i think you're being
competitive now because
and you're not going to quit until i
agree with you no i just want you to
acknowledge
you you i want you to acknowledge you
want to win no no
argument no no i'm trying to get you to
to accept something that i think is true
about you okay so let's say
hit me with it okay we're going on
fallon we both
get suits for fallon okay
when you think about what you're wearing
right you think
we go on fallon and like we come off a
fallon
and then we start looking on the
internet at what people are saying and
like everyone is talking about how
awesome my suit is they're not saying
any they might even be saying that like
what happened with link suit but like
red suit is on fire tonight
like link you already wore that suit
does that bother you
uh yes so in the sense of wanting to
have a cool suit now but
and what i'm saying is you don't exist
for better or worse
neither of us exist in this world of
entertainment as a
as our own entity we are tied to the
other guy we don't do solo projects
we're i'm not off doing things you're
not when we when we present ourselves we
present ourselves as a duo
and like we both are like i'm you know
it's like
when they come and they start fitting
like we're getting ready to get fitted
for like one of these things
and like they're like here's all your
options link and here's all your options
right
and i like look at your options i'm like
man he's got a lot better options than
me you know well he's
he's six feet tall he's not six foot
seven i get it you know it's really hard
to find things for a tall guy
but damn i wish i wish they would bring
me cool suits too
i think i think that's competition i
think the net result of that now it
could get really unhealthy if it was
just like
i want more people to like me than than
like link that's not at all
what i'm what i'm after but i want
people to be like
they they look good those suits look
good
and that may be a shallow thing but i
don't want it to be like
man i went out there in this frumpy bad
fitting suit link looks really sharp
like that purse that
i have a problem with that personally
right i want us both to look good
and so i think that when i'm looking at
your rack of suits
that's a good there's a competition
there the ultimate thing is if you're
focused on that which
my premise is you're just as focused on
that as i am maybe even more
when it comes to certain things right
then uh
then the net result will be like we both
wanted this to come out right and the
net result is both of us wanting that
in a healthy way the net result was as
good as it was the best possible result
you didn't pick a good example because i
i mean what happens with suits
if we're talking because i it's a good
example
in that it's so it's it's the most
superficial thing that we do
right it's incredibly super fast it's
the most you're right because it's like
we you know we have to coordinate
whatever we're going to wear so that
like it doesn't clash
and and we both know that we both want
to look
we want us together as a duo to look as
good as possible what if i was gonna
have a little cool light on my shoulder
and i was like i got this thing on the
suit that it lights up and it like
uh hologram projects my name over my
shoulder
you'd be like well i want one of those
first of all you thought it was a good
idea
i fee i i feel like you you're more
competitive when it comes to this than i
am
i this is why i think it's a bad example
but
you know you have a chip on your
shoulder because your shoulders
so tall in the air you're six foot seven
you have trouble getting clothes that
fit you
so i say you know what every single time
we do this
the system is you go and you try on
you pick out whatever it is works best
for you and then i will come in
and then you say okay this is this is
the best that they've got for me
it's it's frustrating because you know
this is all i could find to fit a man as
big as me right
and then i'm like okay then i have
then i will work around your choices but
you would do you resent that a little
bit
and i will just a little bit you're
you're your argument's floating no no
no i'm just i i feel i don't know what
your point is i feel like you're trying
to say that you don't have any personal
pride and i think
and i'm saying healthy good personal
pride and i think you do
and there's nothing wrong with it and i
think the truth i've said that i care
if if everybody complimented you on your
suit nobody complimented me on our sit
my suit that would hurt my feelings
especially if you had over had to
overlook a cool ass suit because
i had to wear another suit because i'm
tall yes you'd be like man if i had the
other suit on right now if this
dumb dumbass wasn't so tall i'm just
just saying that like
that but it's not and i i'm and i'm not
saying that's
i'm just saying i don't have a problem
with that like i'm just saying
i don't do i think about that in terms
of competition
is is he better i mean when you get into
comparison
is comparison competition i'm just yeah
that's what i'm saying i'm saying yes it
is
and i think that in the context of i i
want
any relationship it's healthy i think
here's the difference
i do think that and again this is on a
spectrum it is not
you're one way i'm another way but like
you have a tendency
you have more of a tendency to look at
something as a
competition meaning only one person can
win
then can't we all just be equal
can't we both just be equal like
um i
i think that i i feel differently about
it
than you do i think i i just i
instinctively look through a different
lens
but what i guess what i'm what i don't
understand is what the
what the lens is i
because if we if you were saying that
i don't actually you care about that and
again this is i do feel judged
by that right because i what i hear you
saying is that no
you got to understand you care about
that you want to look good or you want
to seem funny i'm open to having an
equally flawed lens it's just a
different one and
what i'm saying is i think that you want
to be
you want to express yourself and be
unique and be perceived in a certain way
just like most healthy well-adjusted
people do
yes and i think you want that um
i think you want it just as much as i do
now but yeah but yeah when we get into
like greenwood
i agree with that we're both like i am
no
less flawed than you are no i don't
think it's flawed i'm not
i'm not i'm not saying it's a bad thing
what i think the the thing that is
frustrating
competitive is not a flaw what are the
trials associated with it i feel like
there's what i feel you saying not hear
you saying but
feel you saying is that there is
something wrong with admitting that you
want some attention
and it would be it would be wrong
some so competing for attention whatever
the word might be right
and i and what i'm saying is that in an
entertainment
partnership um
there are certain partnerships where
they kind of came to
some agreement like penn teller right
well you know what i'm not going to one
of them's not going to talk
could you be the guy that didn't talk
hell no and neither could i
but that's not who we are and i'm and
what i'm saying is
yes it could get if it was unhealthy
then we wouldn't still be best friends
and business partners like we have a
we have a um
unprecedented friendship and business
relationship right
like even more so than your typical
you know other comedic duos out there
you got like key and peel like yeah they
made the show together and stuff but
like
they're how often do they see each other
how often are they working together
right and probably not much at all right
now
and i'm not saying that you're not going
to go and do something
by yourself or i'm going to do something
that is i'm passionate about whatever
but i think that i
i think the argument that i'm trying to
make is that there is something
healthy about the friendly healthy
competition between the two of us and
i'm using the term competition
you want to say self-comparison
self-measuring whatever the word you
want to use
that ultimately i think is a benefit and
is a positive thing
but i feel you talking about it in a way
as if
you would be ashamed to admit that that
was a
dynamic and i'm just saying i'm and
maybe i'm really
ready to admit it just because i it does
for me i'm competitive in many other
areas and so
i just naturally map that onto to this
but i don't see the
but the way i see this different is i'm
not trying to win anything
i'm not i'm not trying to
be better get more attention
i'm just trying to make sure that i get
that we are
getting to that 50 50 when we when we do
things and it doesn't always happen and
again i
i think i think i'm defining
a competitive spirit as wanting to win
to outdo it's not yeah and that's not
what i'm talking about then that's not
competition
i think you're not using a good example
i think we both
know that like we are at our best
where when we're when we enable each
other's best
like we don't we are not at our best
independently
right we are at our best corporately
and so
if you know
us being at our best is like we're both
not talking all the time
you know it's like we couldn't hear
anything anyone said if we both talked
all the time or we both listened all the
time
you know as just a dumb example i just
don't feel like
that's i guess i i think i just
different i i have a difference of
opinion about that because
i define being a competitive person is
wanting to win
and then when you bring when you bring
if you were to bring that mentality into
this i mean it's like
i you just you know again it's just a
you like to win and you like to achieve
things and that's good but it's just a
lens that you bring to this
and we have a health we have a we have a
healthy
creative relationship um
and but we look through different lenses
and i guess i don't understand
what your lens is because what i'm
saying is like if we
so like when we're writing buddy system
and
it's like okay we've got this really
funny sort of one-off role
that we've invented for you my natural
instinct is to be like okay
what's the one-off funny end role that
i'm gonna play
all right link is to do this quirky cave
deal
so i'm gonna be the bike or something
like that like
yeah to me i'm just saying i am
i'm being vulnerable here but i'm
readily admitting
that there is a competitive element to
that because if i was like you know what
because even if even if you would be
better at being this
and this i still would make the decision
to advocate for myself to be this
and to you to be that not just because
it makes sense from a retin-linked brand
that yeah that's part of it but also
because
well i wanna i wanna also have a funny i
wanna be a funny guy i
i wanna play the quirky role i
and to me are you saying that that is
not true of you
it's true for me but the the equation is
different like i did
you know i i think the first thing i
think of is like
i i want to i want to contribute i want
to be
you know it's i want to be
i want to pull my weight and i want to
uh
i don't know i guess i i don't want to
be seen
it's like i don't want to be seen as a
loser as like the
the hangar on well that's like but so
it's
again it's the same thing it's just a
it's a different
it it's almost like the negative
viewpoint of the same thing it's like
it's if you're saying i want to win then
i'm saying oh i don't want to lose
yeah that's only right so i and i'm just
saying that
i because i felt right i felt like i was
going crazy
not that you were like gaslighting me
but i felt like i was going crazy
because
what i hear like what i hear you saying
is you know you think
you think those things in in the context
of what we do but you know i don't
really think those things
but what i hear you saying now is i do
think those things
i i think about them differently maybe
through a different lens
but in practice when i look at something
like a script
i immediately look it whoa there's my
name and there's my lines
there's his name and there's his lines
let's make sure those are even
yeah and i feel like us wanting that is
coming from the same place
it's coming from a personal you're a
personal
advocate and but i think that that's
healthy i don't think it can become
unhealthy
if it was i want to dominate i want to
see my name more if you write a script
that's a problem if you write a script
you take that into account
you take balance into account you're not
just you're not trying to make
it you're not trying to make just you
look good if you write something and if
i edit something
i'm not just trying to make me look good
i'm trying to make yesterday and often
and so i might refer and often i might
actually
bias something towards
you having a little bit more you know
what i'm saying like
because i because i if it's if it's a
certain kind of thing that i'm writing
and i'm spending more time on it well i
don't want to be the [ __ ] who like
is also well i'm in control of this at
this stage
yeah and so i'm going to like write more
for myself like
i i actually i think i do the opposite
but
i'm just saying the element the fire the
spark
of being your own advocate and how that
takes place in the context of our
friendship in the context of our
is mostly the context of our creative
partnership because we are
our whole business is based on people
finding us
likeable and enjoyable and funny and one
wanting to sit around and listen to us
talk i don't
and i i i am i'm just trying to
i process honestly and i do think that
like
you know i don't i don't i don't try to
make you look like a jerk in these
conversations
i think you well you do sometimes but i
know you're not trying to i know that
i know you feel like that happens i
honestly
i just i feel like i operated
not out of a desire to win but out of a
desire not to fail
it's just a you know it's just a
different motivation
i think there's a difference it's a
different motivation uh
and so it doesn't feel like but i'm just
saying i think that comes from the same
place
i think it comes from the same place in
a person wanting to
well i think you can have something you
got some personal pride i i think it
uh okay yeah because there are some
people who aren't
what i'm getting at is there are a lot
of people yeah there's pride you don't i
don't want to look
like i said i don't want to look stupid
i don't want to like i lose i don't look
like i'm not pulling my weight i don't
want to be seen as a sidekick
and also and this is why i use the term
competition because there is an
intensity to it right in the midst of a
performance
in the midst of us going out and doing
like we don't do this a whole lot
anymore because we don't go out but
like when we were like shooting uh you
know the backup plan where it's like all
right we're going to go into this
situation
we're going to interact with this person
or commercial kings whatever
we both are like i'm going to try to be
funny i'm
s and and it's like whoa if if
you ramp up and it's like man he's
really knocking it
knocking it out of the park right now
i'm like i gotta get up to that
i gotta get up to that place you know i
gotta get up to that place
to me the net result of that is
well it's twice as funny as it would
have been but there's a lot of people
who's like
man he's really popping off right now
and he's really being funny who would
shrink down
and what i'm saying is and ultimately it
may sound
this is a backwards way to get to it i'm
trying to compliment you
and i'm just trying to get you to accept
the compliment
is that i think that you are a
an uh an equal advocate for yourself
to the degree that i am um
but that you have a little bit of a
problem with accepting that
you don't want to accept that you're an
advocate for yourself
to a to a large degree i i'm not trying
to diagnose you
i'm just i i'm just saying that like my
perception of interacting with you is
that you want it just as much as i do
you want whatever it is we're trying to
forget as much as i do
and that's a good thing and if you
didn't then we wouldn't be here
and so but there's a part of me that's
like you don't want to be perceived
as a guy who really wants it i'll let
him be the one that
seems like he really wants it
i'm not well
first of all i'm not making a i'm not
making a play on this podcast to be
perceived
in a certain way i've never thought
so that that's not what's happening that
like
you know it's
that that dynamic of like what happens
on
what i don't know that's another
conversation for what happens on this
podcast sometimes where it's like
i i feel like we could we both
want the same things but we we don't
have the exact same drive
it's not the same chemical makeup
because we're different
people but you're just as driven as me
that's all i i
i am driven but i don't you know if we
were making it you've made it very
personal and i think it complicates it
because
um if you go back to like just the
simple things like
what kind of sports do you like you know
there's a i think we can we can easily
agree
that you enjoy things that are
competitive
like cardboard competitive much more
than me
yeah and i think this and then this gets
at the root of a big
this i think i have an issue and then
you funnel that back into well no i
think i have an issue with
there's so many people who are like i
don't like sports because i'm not
competitive
but then i'm like well look what you do
for a living like i
i have somebody i know who is a musician
and is very committed to their
art and wants to be good
at it and is incredibly driven um
but it's like i don't really like sports
i don't get it it seems
like i just i'm not competitive i'm not
into competitive things i'm like but you
sure as hell
but you know that i don't judge sports
so let's just lose that for a second
like i don't look down on anybody who's
just trying to scream about sports i
don't i guess what i'm saying is that i
think more people
than and i'm not and again i just this
can come across like i'm trying to and
again i understand
yes i do think there is a dynamic
sometimes where we get into a
conversation like this and i'm
being what i perceive as being
vulnerable which is like i'm kind of
pulling back the
curtain on my on my mind and it's like
oh he's kind of a
things get a little dark in there
sometimes and
i perceive in those moments you trying
to be
like distance yourself from that be like
well that's not i'm not like that i mean
you're like that but i'm not like that
and i and i guess i'm selfishly trying
to say
well not just to make myself feel better
but maybe to make myself feel
sane it's difficult for me to
interpret your actions over the course
of our lifetime
through the lens of you not being
competitive
in the broadest sense i know you're not
competitive when it comes to sports and
and even even most games but i'm saying
i think you're competitive when it comes
to life and i think that
most people even the most humble among
us
who want to be who want to do something
meaningful and impactful in the world um
in fact the the the primary motivation
of of most
people on earth is to just is to be
important
you know and i think that there's
nothing wrong with that it's
basically deeply built in
into our dna and i'm just saying i'm
saying
yes it can get in my way sometimes but
yes i want to be important
and i'm just saying that i think you
also want to be important
but i think i do want to be important i
think that
i think you have more confidence than me
i think you have you have confidence
that you have more to offer than me
so i think and i think that's a flaw
that i have because maybe that's not
true
maybe we we have equal things to offer
maybe everybody has something to offer
and it's not
you know if you you know that's why
comparison is a trap
but like to me
i do think it's two sides
to the same coin of it's like
it's it's really complicated because
it's
uh you know i do find myself
with comparison i i have a it's a
negative experience
for you it might be more of a
frustrating experience of
um you know
i can look better in this suit
it's like can i look better in this suit
i mean i'm not as confident as people
might think i
am i don't know i i just think we're
we're a little bit different
in that way i i as a side note
maybe i do a really bad job of
responding to
you being vulnerable about something and
then it
because if you're asking just like oh
yeah i'm this
if if i can't say i feel exactly the
same way you do when you're being
vulnerable it if that just immediately
is judgment
it's like i don't know it's like that's
a couple a couple of episodes ago i said
something like and i remember that was
saying
something about us being empathetic and
uh i was basically making the statement
like we're both empathetic we're you
know
we're empathetic about different things
or whatever but we're both really
empathetic people
and if if you know what we're talking
about in that conversation just so you
know
listener um kiko actually cut out
once the one statement that i made where
i was like well
i don't know about that because
yeah it was uh it was
it was at least a confusing thing to say
and it sounds like you were saying
well i know that you're not as
empathetic as me is what it sounded like
you were saying
you know what and i'm i'm sorry for
saying that
for the record because okay i accept
your i think i
knew i think i thought i knew what you
were going to say
and then what you said about empathy was
different
but in my mind i was already i i am very
sensitive
i think you're kind of you're getting at
something with me that's like
i'm sensitive to
uh i don't know there's something about
if you do
if you are vulnerable about something or
if you say something about yourself
and then you say but you're the same way
you know it's like well i don't know if
i'm you know
like i i try
i know that i'm very flawed i know that
you're very flawed
we and you know the same thing about me
and i i do know that there's something
about
this forum that
it's harder for people to see that about
you
uh no i'm not i'm not being clear not
that you're more flawed but that like
that that we both got equally good
hearts but they're different
yeah and and i also wasn't trying to
point out
i just have a general i think i have a
knee-jerk response to being lumped into
like
okay my flaws are your flaws like if you
say
but i'm not saying it's a flaw i'm
saying it can be i'm just explaining why
i said something that i'm sorry for
that like i if i implied that you
weren't ever empathetic or
i remember the time i was like that's
not what i meant to say and then i never
went back to it it was difficult to
bring it up so i never did
but it but i thought you were going to
say something else and
all i really heard was i have this issue
but you have it too and i'm like well
don't you know it's it's like when you
say every everybody who's in
entertainment is a narcissist and then
you say
i i so then it's like well i there's a
little bit of narcissism in me there's a
little bit of narcissism in you and i'm
like well
and you're uncomfortable with that and i
get i get i have a
negative response to that and
i haven't fully explored it but i'm like
it's just one thing that for somebody to
be vulnerable themselves but then if you
lump me in
it's like well and i appreciate it
because because i just know that we're
we're both flawed in our own ways but
they're not all the same exact ways and
i'm not saying you're a narcissist and
i'm not i'm just saying that
the general lumping in thing
i appreciate that and when you said that
you're just as empathetic as me
i had a knee-jerk reaction and i said
something that i regret but it's
and i appreciate that but i think what i
guess what i'm saying is
it's also this isn't i wouldn't do this
with anybody else
right i mean maybe with my wife
you know but i i guess what i'm saying
is
a lot of these things are based on
how well i know you so and so
it's so in one sense but i could hear
you saying
you don't know me as well as you think
you do i i i think you're
that's not what i'm what i'm saying is
you're a competitive person
you well you're more competitive than me
and then you see you see the way that i
act and you interpret
my uh motives
as being rooted in competition and i'm
like
i don't know if it's that simple again
if you go back to the
right and it's a it's an interesting
question and i'm really trying to answer
but there's two sides trying to do it to
make you seem
no make me seem right i get that but
there's one side of it which is like
i have a fundamental difference of
opinion about what the word competition
means which i i'm trying to get beyond
that
to what i think is the more important
route which i think as a
i sense like i said a
uh uh and it's interesting it's pretty
ironic
right because um
you're very open you're very open and
you're very vulnerable
in general uh but sometimes
like yeah i think it's like i'm what i'm
looking for is this
like there's a some validation that i'm
looking for
or just uh an acknowledgement that like
yeah yeah i deal with that too
um that your response to it is
well not so fast and the
interpretation that i get and then i get
worried that the audience gets is
oh so link isn't link doesn't have that
struggle or it's so different so as to
be a completely different thing
it because well i guess what i'm getting
at is it's like okay
with what we talked about today if you
aren't advocating for yourself
uh and i'm not saying in
to exclude advocating for me or exclude
advocating for the retin-linked brand or
whatever it is yeah if then then i have
misinterpreted
i don't know where i don't know where
it's coming from and i'm just saying i
i feel like i know you well enough to
know that like yeah he
he wants to be important just like i
want to be important
but that doesn't make you a bad person
because if you didn't want that like i
said everyone wants that
even people who are you know even people
who won't
who struggle from agoraphobia won't
leave the house
right like they still
want to be important and
it's every everybody wants
to to make some kind of impact they may
have
a lot of things that are getting in the
way of that but i don't think that's the
case with you
i think that you make a huge impact so
and i don't think that i don't think
that there's any like at no time in the
history of our friendship or partnership
have i thought that we've started
getting to a place where it's just like
oh this is really imbalanced right like
i've always thought that like we do a
really good
job but that's because we do that for
we defer to each other and we
we he here's it but it's more than just
deferring because we both deferred then
neither
you're setting me up to make you look
like an [ __ ] and then you're being
con
you're being sensitive to it because
you're saying
listen we're both really competitive we
both
really care about looking good looking
just as good as the other person
not beating the other person but looking
as good as the other person i'm like
we both need to care about both of us
together
as a unit looking the best we can look
and that means both of us taking a back
seat at certain points
and i know you agree with that but but
you're just asserting
that you're talking about the one aspect
of that because i agree with all that
again i i is the is just the being the
personal advocate for yourself and i
i still feel you having some shame
around that
that's all that i there's there feels
like there's shame
around being an advocate for yourself
and i'm
al only thing i'm saying is that like it
could be shameful
yeah not because i'm saying but i don't
think we need to be an advocate for
us i completely agree
and i know you agree and because in
practice that's what we do
but i think but i'm just
don't you don't you have a proclivity to
view it more of a
in a more competitive way than i do
between the two of us i i
i feel that like let me throw out i'm
not trying to say that
i i'm not trying to get you to admit
that you're equally as competitive
in all in this even in this realm the
only thing that i'm trying to get
you to admit is that you want to
like you want to pull your weight to the
same degree that i want to pull my
weight
yeah and in the context of a retin link
that means pulling the same amount of
weight as read just like in the context
for me it's pulling the same amount of
weight as
link it's i it's there's a dynamic
that's different than just an
athlete who's just out there doing his
thing
competing against himself or competing
against a bunch of other people
it's it's a it's a duo and there's a
and there's a dynamic to that that i
think in a lot of ways we've
really figured out right because most
duos don't last
but it's but it's not i don't know i
just find myself not thinking that like
i'm ashamed that i don't
uh that i'm competitive i
i don't feel like it gets us
as far as
as working together but again
i don't know maybe that's just a
confidence thing
that's why i brought that up like i i
i think of it here's an example
i don't know if you'll remember well you
have to remember some of this
i don't know why this popped into my
head
when we were doing those song biscuits
okay
so we would we would we would we would
do a podcast with somebody
and this particular time it was nice
peter okay
and we did a podcast and then we then we
sat down and we did a song biscuit where
we write a song together
and we just record the thing for an hour
and we
try to within an hour write and then
perform the song
based on suggestions from twitter
and so we started writing this song from
nice pete with nice peter and like
you know i mean it's
i'm immediately aware that like okay
i'm the guy on the keyboard who's gonna
write down what everybody comes up with
because i
you know i don't play board you mean
laptop not not keyboard the instrument
between the guys in the context i'm the
guy on the laptop
keyboard because i can't play a keyboard
or a guitar
right okay so
i'm i'm the you know i'm i'm not as much
of a contributor here i got to find a
i got to find my lane you know you got
this other guy
pete is like very talented very quick
you know on his feet um we're writing a
song together
everybody's got their own verse we're
writing this thing it was very difficult
for me because it's like it's not just
you and me and like we can work together
and
you know i think this is a good example
i think so you know i remember
i i remember like all of these
comparisons going through my head
you know you use the term comparisons
yeah but because i knew that i couldn't
win
so it's not a competition okay
okay i will use your that's why i'm not
talking
but i'll use your terminology but what
but this is a great example because the
point of
yeah that's the different point of view
between uh how a competitive
lens views that situation i guess i'm
just saying i'm using this
because i think comparative lens because
i think you wanted to have
you know you wanted to have the best
verse you wanted to do the best you
could do
and you wanted the best verse and i
wanted the best verse and pete wanted
the best verse
and what that in my mind what that
contributes to is the best song
right right i specifically remember
being self-conscious about the fact that
he's so much better of a guitar player
than me right yeah and so um and again
is that competitive i think that's
competitive i think it's like man he's
i'm self-conscious because i think you
but he's such a good guitar player so
you're going to step up and you're going
to win and i'm like i got to find my
lane because i'm going to lose
and i think that and i think i think
that's the same thing that's and that's
what i'm saying is different
okay and i just think that yeah i i
i yeah i got to find my lane and then
what i did in that situation is i played
rhythm and he played like lead right
because yeah i can't like i can't
compete with him
i i'm not going to be better at the
guitar than him but what can i do
to contribute because i do have a guitar
and i want to keep up with him
so it wasn't like let's beat pete it was
more like
i think i'm thinking the same thing
what's my lane in this situation
one of them is writing as good of a
verse as i can
so that not so that people will be like
had the best verse
because that would be unhealthy but if p
but if people would be like
man pete and link were really funny and
rhett wasn't
like i i would have a problem with that
yeah and i feel like if i didn't have a
problem with that
i would be a shitty entertainer yeah and
i just felt like
you know in that instance like okay i
can't play to my strengths here and it
was like
and i remember there was a point where
like
unlike how we would usually do it that
would we would be writing the version
very collaboratively i remember there
was a point where
every like
we sketched out the verses then
everybody went
the two of you went like you were
working on your own verse
because i think pete was like i need i
can't remember how it happened
but it was just like oh this became a
every man for himself
writing their own thing and coming up
with how they're gonna do it and i was
like
i hate this you know this is not how i
want this to go
and it was just because i felt like but
you didn't
but this is the difference between you
and someone who
i would say is not competitive
is that you didn't implode
and not do a good verse you were like
damn i got to write a good verse the
same thing that i think i was thinking
no i was thinking why aren't all three
of us writing all
these verses together but that's to me
that
yeah that that's a that's a separate
concern but because
once a competitive person says i'm gonna
this is my thing
i'm gonna make it as good as possible
i'll be back and that's what happened
it's like
and i i did never i never had the
instinct
hey guys let me go over here on my own
and make my thing as good as it can be
because i know you guys are going to do
that but see my observation of you as a
person
is that any time you have to do
something you fully commit to it and
make it as good as it can be
yeah so i guess what i'm saying is is
that in
my mind there are plenty of people
in the world who given the opportunity
to do something
in the context of someone else doing the
same thing
back away and say i don't want to be a
part of this but like you don't
i couldn't do that yeah but i'm saying
you don't there's
nothing in the final product there's
nothing in your
what you say all your actions and all
your
outward emotions communicate to me
that you're trying at least as hard as i
am
and so maybe i'm interpreting that wrong
but to me it's just like oh he wants
this too
to the same degree that i do and that's
a good thing like i
i at no point during any of the this
whole conversa
two-hour conversation have i
been trying to say just admit you're bad
like me
which again i feel like that's what i
hear you saying
you want me to admit i'm bad like you
because you keep using the word flaws
and stuff
i'm not actually in this instance i'm
very flawed but in this instance i'm not
i i'm actually trying to get to a place
where and this is
to to unpack a whole different layer
like the whole issue of being a personal
advocate
and be and having some pride coming from
an evangelical christian background
that's something that i've had to come
to grips with is being okay
my wife is the same way especially as a
woman coming up in the evangelical
environment being an advocate for
yourself felt dirty and it felt like you
were being sinful and you were being
prideful in the bad way
and that's a huge part of our psyche and
a huge part of our background and sort
of our
foundational philosophy is that the
moment you become an
advocate for yourself and you realize
you know i actually do
want to be funny or i do want to seem
important
that's all bad all the time and i think
over the past few years i'm kind of
coming to
a the realization that you know what
being an advocate for yourself
is actually a healthy thing when it's
funneled
in into the right thing and it doesn't
go overboard and it doesn't happen at
the expense of other people
and what i hear you saying is that i
want it to contribute to the whole and
so do i i feel like me focusing on
me being the best rhett i can be
makes the best rhett and link we can be
and i
i think what i'm looking for is you to
be like yeah i feel the same way
just so i don't feel crazy
i feel like i do want to be
the best i can be
but i think that if we only focus
on that then it we will never be the
best we can be because
we have to also focus on like
when being a champion for when it's the
the other guy's time to shine and i
completely agree with that
the only thing i'm saying is that the
portion of that equation
which is you being your own personal
advocate is something
that i feel like i'm saying
yes that's a part of who i am
and i can say it and i don't even have
to qualify it with the fact that yes and
it
makes it better as a whole did you say
that in life
and in the context of our partnership
i'm trying to be the best that i that i
can be and
it yes it is partly motivated by wanting
to be personally meaningful and
important and have an impact
the worst thing that can happen to a
person is to get to a place where they
feel like they have no
impact i i want i
i want to be successful i want to be
seen as talented i want to you know i
want to i want to get compliments on my
suit
i want i want all of these things you
know and
um i don't think it's healthy to want it
at your expense
and i don't think you're saying that i
agree um
but i have this but we have a different
makeup and i think that there
that confidence is a component of it i
think when i played soccer
i hated every minute of it because i
never believed
that i could score yeah i never believed
i could score
i the entire game was trying
to not screw up
yeah i get it but i don't think that was
your mentality when you played
you're like you're right i want to be
the i i can score i was trying to win
you're right i will win yeah and i'll be
like i don't want to lose
it's just like i don't and i think
that's a thing i think that's a
significant difference and i and i
and i and i think what i guess what i'm
saying is to me that defines
you're writing it if you're a
competitive person you're riding in a
slightly different vehicle
right but you you but the gas the juice
is the same you you may be right you may
be
taking a different road but i'm just
saying that that juice
that fuels it of you don't want to fail
i want to win i'm just saying
and by the way coming from the same
place by the way i don't want to i don't
want to say that and i don't want to
show that like like i don't want to say
hey man can you help me write the melody
for my verse because i feel like yours
is a whole lot better than mine and
pete's is better than both of ours but
at least ours can be equal
like i'm never going to say that because
that's being more of a loser
you know it's like yeah and i'm just
saying that i
i agree and i so i i
i think you're saying you think you're
as as i'm as competitive as you when
like
really i'm just you know i don't want to
be the lame duck at the game
maybe this game sucks i don't i'm not
you don't want to lose as much as i want
to win
i i guess what i'm saying is i see a
fire
in a like a very motivated
focused person and
what i hear when you say that and also
when other people say it is this like
i'm not really passionate you know what
i'm saying i'm not as
passionate as you but i don't believe
that about you or these other people
that i'm thinking about like
like no you might be more passionate
than me actually
but you just don't want to admit it for
some reason like you
you don't want to admit that you want
something as readily as i am willing to
admit that i want something
and i in and i'm and i'm just saying
that i think you want it just as bad as
i do
but you may say well i want it in a
different way i don't want to lose
and so when i think about us going out
and creating something
my preoccupation is i don't want this to
suck and us to be embarrassed
and you're thinking i want this to be
awesome so people will think we're great
and i'm willing to admit that that could
be a fundamental difference between the
two of us
and probably a strength in some way but
i guess what i'm just saying is the want
the desire like i don't you don't wake
up in the middle
in the morning not wanting something
you know what i'm saying like my
experience with you in the world
is that you're very motivated
it may be a slightly different flavor of
motivation
but it's not like well you know in this
partnership one of them is really
motivated and the other one is not
it's like no that's no it has never been
the
the yeah the sense well
i hate i don't i don't want to be
contrary you you just
this is a strange time right
and i do think so i i think i just want
you to say yeah man i think what you're
saying is true
but i also think that i have struggled
with motivation the most i've ever
struggled
in quarantine like like
and i know you have to because we've
talked about it right because so i'm
like very
very in this local moment but like but
people who struggle with motivation
are motivated it's just like it's just
like my pastor it's just like my pastor
used to say
you know this there's this thing that
you know you
you back when i was a christian and you
would wonder if you were saved
i don't know if i really prayed the
sinner's prayer that last time you know
i prayed it
several times i got saved multiple times
and rededicated my life and
all the things that you do in that
environment and
and when and my wife struggled with the
same thing
and you know my pastor told me one time
he was like listen
people who are worried about their
salvation
they're not the ones if you're if you're
worried about whether or not you're
saved or not
you're saved you know what i'm saying so
it's so
what i'm saying is that so if i'm
worried about
you're sitting around thinking about not
being motivated well the person who
isn't sitting around thinking about
being motivated they're the ones who
aren't motivated
you know what i mean you are motivated
you you you you know what you
frustrated yourself yes because you
don't have something to focus on right
now right because we don't have a
routine and we're not coming into the
office everything
i feel the same way but that is just
evidence of motivation
i'm just saying you're motivated okay so
all right
all right i'm competitive man i'm just
as competitive as you yeah
does that mean
it took two hours and 13 minutes
no you don't have to be you don't have
to say you're competitive that's if
that's not the word you want to use
your let's just use the term motivated
you are just as
motivated as me oh gosh
we have not neither one of us have moved
an inch no i think so i think i think we
both have
i think we both have i think that
i think we've learned a lot i think i
don't know i think
we've impacted i think we acknowledge
the fundamental difference
with the way that we see
competition there's a fundamental
difference
i want to win you don't want to lose and
that is a meaningful
difference
but what i hope we have established is
it's not
that like i'm mr i want to be mr
fantastic and you're like i'm i just
want rhett and link to be the best that
they can be
i think we both want to be mr fantastic
but we also want rhett and link to be
mrs fantastic and i think that
that motivation is one of the reasons
that we have
against all common sense worked
as hard as we have worked for as long as
we have done it i think
oh god i think if we were
if we were both never mind i'm not going
to say it
because i don't know if it i don't it's
i don't know it's like we're we're
different people
like yeah i know you know that we're
different people but it's like we're
more different
i don't know it's
there's other factors and it's you we're
just talking about
competitive spirit and like how we view
that type of thing but i think we've
stripped away too much
of who we are and trying to isolate this
thing and
we're maybe drawing too many conclusions
that's a that's actually how i feel
about it
i i wonder how people listening to this
are going to process it
you know well a lot of people will stop
by now
it's like i'm not gonna listen to these
guys psychoanalyze each other that's why
when this is over we'll have an argument
about making this a two-part
no we can't do that i think we can put a
thing at the beginning that says listen
something happened in this episode and
we went from tomat games
and then we just air biscuits man then
we don't have to record one for next
week
and this is a really good i i want
people to listen to the second half of
this conversation
so that's why we're gonna have an
argument about should this be
and this won't be in it because we'll
cut this out that way we they won't know
who
who who won because as you know i'm very
competitive and
yeah exactly see you you are you want to
advocate for your position just as much
as me
and you say that you don't i don't want
people to not listen to this
conversation
so i want it to be front and center and
it should be its own podcast i think
it's an important conversation it
shouldn't be buried
after talking about uh board games
and movies for an hour it's it's too
it's too important of a conversation
that first episode is not going to be as
good as it could be
it's as good as last week's episode you
know me i'm not competitive so i'm
totally willing to do
what you're asking i mean i'm fine with
this this episode competing
with last week's episode you know it's
like
you did a great job on on on the last
episode
i sucked i had nothing that i had
nothing to bring to the table
see these are the things that i think
about i'm very comfortable and is that
competitive i don't think that's
competition i'm super comfortable
talking about all this
and you're getting there
what what are you talking about i'm just
joking man i don't i don't i don't get
the joke
um okay this is the second part of a
two-part
episode that we have to go back and so
that means that
um this is gonna be complicated because
i have a wreck but my wreck is gonna be
inserted at the end of this episode or
the end of the previous episode
this episode so you get two wrecks in a
row that's what that's gonna
i'm joking not just came out of my head
i'm joking
i'm joking so you want me to give my
wreck at the end of this full long
episode which i actually i think i don't
want to get you give a wreck at all
unless
it's appropriate no actually i think it
is appropriate because good
um and this is a this is the last
episode
part one of this did not have a wreck
because it just continued
i can put an addendum on it okay i was
kind of thinking you should give you a
wreck that you were going to get but you
could save the wreck that you were going
to give
um it actually i think it influenced the
the nature of this conversation is a is
a book that i'm in the middle of reading
which is like almost 100 years old and
has a sort of a title that's a turn off
and you've heard of it before it's dale
carnegie's
how to win friends and influence people
and this is a classic i would never read
that book
uh based on the title well it's been
recommended
by so many people that i respect and i
was like if one more person how to buy
friends and manipulate people
nope how to win friends and influence
people and by the way
it was recommended during staff training
for campus crusade but apparently you
didn't take that recommendation at that
point neither did i
um it's an old school book
i recommend just doing the audiobook
because of the nature of the language
it's the kind of thing you probably get
lost in the reading um
but is this just essentially how to be
a person and
just like things like when you're
actually
trying to interact in the world and do
the things that you want to do
and interact with people they're just
some very simple and again i'm like
a third or a half of the way through
this but just like some things that i
was like
everything so far is common sense but
you're kind of like yeah i don't know
why
i don't operate in this way more
like if you can praise somebody
it's always going to be better than
criticizing somebody
just simple things like that that were
very helpful in thinking about just
being a boss
you know being a manager of people uh
being a friend
and just being a person who moves about
the world
so again i can't speak for the second
half of the book it may get
really on pc or something probably i
mean it's 100 years old they probably
updated it since then
i don't i have no reason to believe that
it would be the second half of the book
is racist
it may get really racist in the second
half no i don't think it is because lots
of people still recommend it
um how to win friends and influence
people just
read it now it's like seven and a half
hour audio book just listen to it
you can listen to on 1.5 speed probably
i'm doing like 1.2 speed
1.25 i think it's just about as fast as
i like to get yeah i can do like 1.3
uh but the reason i'm um
uh that's the joke the reason that i am
saying it relates is because he talks
about the fundamental
uh drive of most of all people is the
desire to be important
and he's like it's like remember
people's names and say them to them
be genuinely interested in people
because
you being and again this can seem like
manipulation but when you're a person
who like smiles at people which i don't
smile a lot it's like i should be
smiling more
i should be saying people's names to
them yes you can use some of these
things to manipulate people and get what
you want but it's very clear that this
is not about that this is about
being a good human to other humans
and being a good human means being
interested and
genuinely curious about people uh but
that whole thing about everybody wants
to be important it's just like it just
hit me
hard i was just like yeah this you can
pretty much
look at everybody's life and everybody's
actions
from people who are doing good in the
world to people who are doing bad in the
world and it feels like a common
denominator is people want to be
important
and you can take that and you can it can
become a bad thing but i do think that
it's just intrinsic to everybody so to
deny it
i'm not saying you're denying i'm not
denying i'm not saying you're denying
not denying it i
i want i want to i felt i felt that you
were denying it and what i felt and i
was wrong so i'll admit this
is i felt like you were saying well you
know you want to be important but
i just want to be and i want
us to be great and i'm in and so yeah
and i know that
that's not what you're saying that's
what i heard that's what i felt and i
didn't want people
you know i was worried you know because
i want to be important i don't want to
seem like an [ __ ]
so i didn't want people to interpret
that um but that's why it works out as a
good wreck because
uh it kind of is based on that and when
you accept that about people
you start realizing that like oh if you
every time you're dealing with somebody
understanding that they
want to be important and they actually
find what they're doing you can use
it sounds like you could use that
knowledge in service
of them and not just yourself yeah yeah
it's a if you're looking to motivate
somebody it's not
you telling them what you want from them
but it's finding out what they want
and figuring out if there's a way to
funnel what they want
into what the group wants you know and
what if what you want as a company or
what you want in a relationship
uh not to manipulate but just to you
know make things better for
for everybody how to win friends and
influence people by dale carnegie
published first in 1936.
second half is racist maybe no we
probably not probably not probably
probably not yeah
hopefully not yeah uh wow
okay use hashtag your biscuits
let us know what what you think and it's
not about let me know where i went wrong
it's not about taking sides uh it's
about continuing the conversation so
hashtag air biscuits let's keep this
conversation
going um but
not in a not in a comparison taking
sides kind of way but
like in a hey let's all understand
ourselves and humanity and psychology a
little bit more
we'll talk at you next week we're still
good we're still good we're still good
we're good we're great i mean it does
feel a little weird but we're still good
and i'm glad we did it talk at you next
week all right
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best